Hey, everyone. Unfortunately, Laura couldn't join us today
for this episode. So, obviously, there's about 200%
less snarky comments. Well I'll let you decide
if that's a win. Sorry. I sent an
AI ducky instead. Speaking of ducky's, if Karai
looks like a statue for the last five
minutes, don't adjust your screen. The machines let
us down. We tried to fix them with
AI, but David's Linux machine is about as
useful as a ducky at fixing video. Enjoy
this episode. Welcome, and thank you for joining
me on today's episode of Cloud Native Compass.
Hello, Karai. For anyone who's not familiar with
your work, could you please take a few
moments just to tell us a little bit
about you? Yeah, sure. So, yeah, my name
is Karai. I'm Turkish. I live in Istanbul.
Nowadays, for the last almost four years, worked
for a company called Kubernetes, where we help
people or help companies with their cloud native
and Kubernetes journeys.
Prior to that, I worked as
DevOps engineer,
operations
engineer,
SysAdmin.
So I was always on the operations
side. I would say I've never worked as
a developer.
I mean, from
Unix Linux background,
but yeah, nowadays it's Kubernetes
mostly. I
married,
I have two kids.
Life is fun with them and also with
cloud, everything.
I was selected as CNCF
ambassador since last year. I have also bunch
of certificates now. I'm a cube astronaut.
They will announce a golden cube astronaut soon,
I think, which is for the old CNCF
certificates.
But I don't think I'll go for that
one, but yeah, we'll see. Awesome. Yeah,
that's mostly it about me. All right. Thank
you for sharing all that. I am also
married with two kids and fun isn't normally
the word I call it. Yeah, want to
say fun, that's yeah, yeah, because they are
my kids, they are my kids, I say
fun, but bunch of other descriptions for that
I totally agree.
Alright, awesome. Again, thank you for sharing. So
let's dive into that a little bit. Cloud
native and Kubernetes for four years now. Yep.
Now as a CNCF ambassador, and congratulations on
that. It's a fantastic tale to hold. Thanks.
I'm assuming you've been in this space
for a while. So could you maybe share
and let us understand how did you end
up in this whole Kubernetes cloud native landscape?
You need to be lucky to start working
for a company like Kubernetes where
their main work is Kubernetes and cloud native.
So there is a job opening and a
lot of really qualified people apply for it,
but then you somehow
go through
the path and take the job. But for
me, at the beginning of my career, I
was mostly on the telco side, telecoms IT
side, about
working with the rating charging applications,
billing applications, that sort of stuff.
That space is, you just work with mainly
closed source, that software from companies like Ericsson
or Huawei, and that's the main thing. But
I always wanted to work for more on
source side more and more. My initial more
DevOps like work was at Ebank in The
Netherlands. I was part of DevOps team, we
were actually having those really CICD pipelines and
everything, so more like edge work.
And then I joined the company here in
Turkey where all the infrastructure was on Google
Cloud, on GCP,
which also contains some GKE clusters as well.
I had started to work with OpenShift before
while I was at ING. So some initial,
let's say, or introduction to
Kubernetes containers more. But then after I changed
my job, so I just had to work
with the containers,
GKE clusters,
also
a lot of other services from GCP,
which was fun. And I learned a lot
there. And later on, I joined Kubernetes. So
you only work with managed
services like Cheeky or EKS.
You learn some part of the Kubernetes. Mainly
you learn to
run your applications, run your workloads.
But of course, there are more to actually
manage the cluster itself with its upgrades and
stuff. So when you work on a managed
environment,
someone else does it for you or makes
your life easier about that point. But later
on, I also started to work more on
managing or not design, but architecting
clusters, the environments, infrastructures.
So back to the question, how I ended
up there, I really wanted to do this,
but I was also lucky that it was
after pandemic,
like towards the end of pandemic, looking for
a remote job and found it there and
somehow
passed the old interviews and got it, I
don't know, luck somehow.
Of course you find your way, of course
you show that you are capable of doing
the job, etc. But in the end, I'm
quite happy with that. Yeah, what is it
they say? Luck is just, you know, where
skill meets preparation.
Yeah. So I'm assuming when you were working
for ING,
was no Kubernetes there, right? No, there was
a project to move towards OpenShift
a little bit. Not there yet. At least
my team, we were preparing our applications to
move containers
at that time, but then I left. I
think they continued. But my first introduction to
Kubernetes was there with OpenShift.
Well, they're probably not there yet. I mean,
no disrespect to ING, but all banks seem
to move at a glacial pace. And that's
because the sensitivity of their product and their
data and all of that stuff is governed
so much so that it slows it down.
Yeah, exactly. It's quite hard for telco companies,
for banking
to move towards. Definitely, they can't move to
public clouds,
at least for their core services, maybe their
websites or like some other stuff might be
some, I don't know, not data driven services
might be running on the public clouds, but
definitely not their core services. It's also issue
here in Turkey as well. There are, yeah,
they just can't use AWS or GCP because
there is no data center here. You are
not allowed to send the data out of
the country, like call records or bank bank
account records, etcetera. Either they have their own
data centers, their own on premise cloud, or
there are companies who do that for them,
of course. But, yeah, it's
not the same scale comparing to the other
ones. Alright. Well, I'm curious about I love
the fact that you're a trainer and a
consultant. So you're seeing multiple angles here. You're
helping individuals and companies and teams level up
their their skills. But as a consultant, you're
also navigating architect and guiding, etcetera. And
now that we are over ten years and
to this Kubernetes thing is is ten years
old as a project. Yeah. What is
what is the skill level like? What is
the knowledge of people that you're working with
these days? Have they had have they ever
worked with containers before, but they want Kubernetes?
Have they just decided Kubernetes,
even though they've got monoliths, like what does
that look like? There are both of them.
So
exactly some people get the training. Some people
even we had some companies
where they get even Linux fundamentals training because
all they do is on Windows all the
time. So we just tell them, yeah, let's
start with Linux because
you will need it, at least some basic
understanding of how it works or what you
do. And then we go with the container
fundamentals and then Kubernetes fundamentals, etcetera, that sort
of stuff. So there are still companies who
have never used containers
before, or they're on the way
to start migrating. Those are the ones that
get the training, right? So they want to
migrate to containers or Kubernetes in general. So
that's why they get the training. But there
are also other companies where,
I don't know if it's right to say,
but for example, they want to get away
from VMware to some other solution. They've already
using Tanzu, but due to the So they
know Kubernetes,
but they need some other sort of solution
because of yeah, licensing or whatever. Those are
also there, but both of them
exist.
And for us, for the people, probably for
you as well, Kubernetes is kind of not
boring, but
yeah, we learned it and we know how
it works. But for some people, it's some
brand new technology. Sometimes I get surprised when
I see on LinkedIn, there are posts like,
Hey, here's how you can best practice for
Docker files. I'm like, yeah, for me, this
was like ten years ago. I'm not ten,
five years ago, six years ago, but for
some people it's brand new. So
both of them exist. And another question or
another angle is that does everyone need to
move to containers? Everyone need to move to
Kubernetes?
That's also another question. I mean,
I think it's not for everyone
like- Definitely.
Not for their use case. If their use
case is
supporting it, then it's good. Again, multiple parameters,
some parameters are based on the regulations
like having data centers, local data centers, etcetera.
But some of them are just, they are
too big companies to
make changes easily. That's also other case,
I think. Or they are just happy with
their current infrastructure. It works fine and they
just don't want to change it. That's that's
also there. Yeah. So two things there. The
VMware Broadcom is causing hysteria and mass migrations
across our industry. I I see it in
the limited capacity that I work with other
companies. Yep. But I I I ask curious
about that question because I go to a
lot of conferences and at those conferences, occasionally,
do three Kubernetes
trainings or half days or or whatever. Mhmm.
And it's hard for me to gauge how
many people are just gauge. Gosh. I don't
even know what that word is now. It's
hard for me to understand.
People are just there because the training happens
to be a conference they're at versus the
people are specifically looking for Kubernetes Because I
often find
the people in that room and again, it's
Kubernetes trading.
When I ask them, have you used containers
before? It's still rare for
more than half the room to have their
hands up. Right? It's still the minority of
people that have played in used containers.
Yeah. Forget even asking if they're using containers
in production because it's still usually one or
two hands. Yeah. Yeah. And then you say,
who understands container technology and Linux primitives? And,
again, almost zero hands are going up. And
I never know if it's just because these
people are just using the training because they're
there, or maybe they're just being told they
need to learn Kubernetes because let's face it,
we're now in 2025 at a point where
Kubernetes is this huge project with so much
momentum powered by the CNCF,
biggest conferences we've got and people just feel
like I have to learn this thing.
But they've not been through the struggles and
tribulations to understand why that thing is important.
And I I was just curious from because
you do a lot more training and consulting
of whether that is something that you're seeing
as well.
Yeah. Yeah. Is definitely. From what you said,
I think you are right. You're this is
the same at least at some at
least to some degree, this is the same
journey that people are taking with your treatment
and consulting. Yeah, exactly. Again, there are people
who have already been playing with and they
just want to change their tooling to something
else.
But there are a lot of people,
it's true. So there are people who have
never done it or never worked with containers
before. That's fine. Maybe their company was not,
they didn't need to.
But there are also people who have been
working with it for a couple of years,
but they haven't understand
what's happening under the hood. That's also, I
think, I mean, people can argue that it's
not important for a developer to understand. They
just need to run their code. Someone just
packages it, like packages it as a container
and deploys it. In the end, the application
is running. But I think to make use
of
the whole platform in the right way, I
think everyone needs to understand how it actually
works. What's happening there? What the container is?
Why it's there? Or what the pod is?
What you can do with the pods, what
sort of configurations or options you have there.
I think these are all important
stuff. So I've seen many cases people running
their pods or containers in privilege mode. Is
there any reason for that? No. There are
some pods that needs run-in the privilege mode.
Yes. But not probably
your normal workload, right? People
just copy paste stuff. And then if it
works and then they continue with it or
they just take it for granted and just
use it. But I think learning is important
about how it's going. And
there is also a fact that the Kubernetes
is quite complex system.
So yes, it makes it easy. I mean,
if you only want to do a deployment
of your application, it's easy. You just write
some YAML files, you have your container, it
just works.
But there are a lot of different stuff
going on happening in the background. So for
any system, I think also if you are
Linux admin or if you are Java developer,
you need to understand how the
whole stuff is happening, how the garbage collection
is happening. So I also in the past
worked with some developers that they have no
idea about the garbage collection or how it
works or how it can be configured.
So that's, I think, general problem that people
don't care about this, but I think that's
the important part which makes the difference
whether you are a good developer or a
good IT person or do things right.
Yeah. I think you're right. Learning is
it never stops. Yeah. Yeah. That's true. Kubernetes
is certainly not slowing down in the last
ten years. Yeah. It's practice changing more now
than it ever did. And I love what
you said there, right? Everyone
I think all online content is guilty of
this, and I'll put my hand up sometimes
to say I do this. Yeah. Giving someone
a YAML to do a deployment to Kubernetes
cluster doesn't teach people how to run workloads
on Kubernetes as 1% because,
of course, we've got the substrate. There's a
control plane, the API server, the Kubernetes, all
that. Now a lot of people can avoid
that. They can use managed services.
But even even that little bit on the
top, a little bit, the massive bit on
the top, you know, to
let me rephrase this question. When you're teaching
people Kubernetes,
do you teach them to work with deployments
and services and endpoints and
stop?
Or do we set aside twelve days and
say, okay. Now we have to learn get
ups. Now we have to learn observability.
Now we have to learn continuous delivery. Now
we've got to do progressive rollers. Now we've
got to do automation within the cluster. Like,
the land the surface of knowledge that people
need not just to deploy to Kubernetes, but
to be successful with Kubernetes
is a volatile landscape itself. I'm curious how
you tackle that.
The trainings, we have some agenda and talk
about those, but not like in deep, to
be honest. So it's also, for example, the
GitOps question always comes in, how do we
do this or can we do that this
way, etcetera.
For the trainings,
we do or I do in general is
that we talk about the objects,
at least the
core objects and some extra ones like additional
ones like ingress, etcetera,
about what they do, why they are there,
the relation between the pod and the replica
set and the deployment and why stateful set
is there, why we have daemon sets, etcetera,
that sort of stuff, to understand how they
work, why they exist, etcetera. But then there
are a lot of other topics. So these
are like mentioned on the surface. Yeah, because
of time limits, of But
I try to direct people to those topics.
You need to maybe look at the service
meshing.
You might need it. You don't have to
have service mesh, but you might need it
for this and that.
Yeah, you may need to use,
you should use GitOps approach.
Which one, it doesn't matter if ArgoCD or
Flux, whichever works for you. I like Flux
more. ArgoCD is great. But yeah, in the
end, it's about the result, right? So if
you have
your manifest somewhere and then managing
your cluster over those manifests, it's great. Doesn't
matter which tool you are using. Yeah, I
like that approach. Like teach people the primitives.
Yeah. Teach them everything that they need to
know and then give them a map of
the landscape for them to follow their path
after that, because everybody, what they're trying to
get out of Kubernetes is gonna be different
depending on their use case and what they're
trying to do with Exactly. And also the
landscape is like too broad. There are
too many stuff that we can talk about.
Yeah. It's also hard to keep up with
what's happening,
what's new tools. So you probably heard there's
a new tool, Krow, Kubernetes resource operator from
AWS, GCP and Azure. They
will be supporting that project. So it's like
cross plane to some extent, but not exactly
cross So you can simply create CRDs and
create another object like, I don't know, test
environment,
which consists of some deployments, maybe some database
on GCP or AWS, etcetera, that sort of
thing. But it's quite in early stage when
it's new.
Every day there is some new project, new
things happening,
and it's really hard to keep up with.
And also
sometimes there are very
powerful tools which is supported by that huge
company. And then another huge company says that,
hey, we have this one, which is faster
or it is blah, blah, blah. And then
you need to know both of them because
especially in our case, sometimes customer says, yeah,
we are on this platform. We want to
use this. And then they are on that
platform, they want to use that. You can't,
my job is not to mandate to or
tell people to use
OPA or Kiverno. I say like, hey, if
you have OPA already use it, but if
you want to have a new policy engine,
Kiverno is more Kubernetes native. Okay, it's that
one, but it's your decision.
And then they say this and that. So
too many things to follow, not easy. Yeah.
When I go to conferences,
occasionally people will ask what cloud native database
should I be using or what message queue
is the best right now. And I hate
those questions because one, my my default answer
is what day of the week is it
because this stuff changes all the time. But
secondly, asking what the best is comes down
to actually understand what you're trying to get
out of it. The best database is okay.
Do you want something stable that never changes,
but it is performant? Go with Postgres. But
do you want something that's future phasing and
doing cool stuff with rust and IO urging?
Oh, then maybe you should go see SeqStorm
or something. There's no right or wrong answer
here. I think it comes down to just
giving people that confidence and the ability to
explore this landscape in a way that makes
sense for them because the tools I pick
are not gonna be the tools that you
pick. And the tools that you pick are
not gonna be the tools that someone else
over there picks. And that landscape document is
just wild, isn't it? Yeah, exactly. Yeah. Just
like I said about Flux and Argo CD,
I like Flux more because for me it's
more GitOps
style than Argo CD, but Argo CD is
also great. It's not a bad product or
something. It's doing a great job and a
lot of people using it. I also use
it for with clients and projects,
whichever works for you, whichever you feel like
is better suited for your case. I think
that's fine. But again,
you need to follow many things and I
totally agree. There's there's no answer for which
one is the best. Which one suits you
best is would be a better question. Just
like you mentioned, like what you want and
then
based on your requirement, this would be the
best option. I think that's but again, to
be able to do that, you need to
first know what you want. And second, which
tool provides that for you. All right. Now,
just to put you on the spot, go
against everything you've just said now. I'm gonna
ask you to see what is your preferred,
not best, preferred C and I? To see
you.
Choice.
Alright. What's your preferred flavor of managed Kubernetes?
GKE.
Alright. Alright. Silly and JKE, that is the
best because we both agree. Everyone listening, that's
the one you should be using. Thank you
very much. Alright. No. But serious talk. See
this talk again. Now, obviously,
some people listening to this are gonna be
hearing us talk about the complexities of Kubernetes,
the evolving cloud native landscape, and maybe be
a little bit worried about
do they even want to be in this
industry anymore because how the hell can they
keep up? There is a time and a
place to learn all the bets underneath
the under the water of the iceberg. And
sometimes you could just skate along the top
and have the managed service. And you're training
and consulting. What is there any heuristics you've
got to understand or help people understand? Are
there any heuristics that you have came up
with that help people understand when to make
that decision of just managed service versus getting
into the weeds of Kubernetes and cloud native?
In our case, to go back a little
bit,
product, Kubernetes product is simply to manage multi
clusters on multi different clouds or multi different
providers. So simply when we have, when you
install KKP,
you kind of have, you are able to
provide managed Kubernetes to your clients, internal, external,
whatever on different clouds. In that sense, what
we are providing is like
our customers become
or are able to have or provide many
services to many Kubernetes
classes to their customers. So in that sense,
that's my go to part mainly because we
either sell this product and then working with
it, or we are doing POCs, etcetera. But
to your question in general, I think the
first thing is about the experience
and number of people or the team size
of how you can manage the infrastructure
in general. So you will probably not have
one Kubernetes cluster,
but you will probably have a database
or some other infrastructure
as well. And if you are already on
public cloud, then I think with a small
team, it makes sense to use a managed
service because you get some help already for
the upgrades, for the maintenance or
health of the cluster in general. But if
you're on prem already and you have to
do things on prem, then you don't have
many options. Yeah, that's
it's there. I mean, you will have to
deal with but it's also okay, I think,
if you want to have more freedom.
For example, when you have a GKE cluster,
you have a certain CNI installed there. So
if you want to use Cilium, then you
have to do a lot of extra stuff
to make it install. I tried it once.
I wasn't successful. I didn't care. I just
tried to do it. I think it can
be done. It's documented. But yeah, you
can't make that choice. Or the choice to
have some other control plane tools, or you
cannot, for example, open feature gates on the
API server because you just use whatever is
provided by them. But if you are experienced,
if you need those kind of stuff, I
mean, if you have the team to be
able to manage things, then just creating a
few on the cloud using Kube ADM to
create a cluster is also fine or some
other tools to have a cluster is there.
But I think my main concern would be
the experience
again.
And also if you really need to
make customizations
to that clusters.
If you don't need it, then yeah, I
think it's If you only want to run
a couple of workloads,
then I think you can just go with
the managed service,
which would make the life easier for you.
Yeah. I think that's a pretty solid answer.
If you're a one or two person team,
the operational complexity of Kubernetes and managing that
is gonna
be tough. Right? Yeah. I'm not even talking
about bare metal, even running that on the
cloud is going to be tough. Upgrades don't
always go seamlessly.
I think managed services
are probably the the best approach for most
people, but I liked your caveat as well.
Kubernetes is a fast evolving project. It does
have feature case. It does have things you
can configure at each level of the control
plane. And if you need that level of,
I don't know, configuration to a point, if
you're doing HPC,
then yeah, you're going to have to go
alone and you're going to have to configure
it this way. And then if you are
on bare metal,
good luck because storage on bare metal is
such a huge problem. True. There are also
not many solutions there and they all have
issues, let's say. They're all expensive either is
your time or
is money expensive?
I agree. All right. So I'm curious then,
you're a well versed person in Kubernetes and
cloud native. I'm assuming you're always looking at
new shiny technologies.
Is there anything in the future that you
think is gonna play a bigger part in
our industry? Any technologies that you're interested and
excited by playing with experiment with anything like
that? I'm not very good at about to
predict the future, about technical stuff.
Yeah, nowadays
AI is the whole buzzword and everyone is
talking about it and also- We almost made
an episode without saying AI. Yeah, sorry
about No, I will not say, but the
thing is that CNCF is also pushing it
to run the AI workloads on Kubernetes as
well to make things together.
So I think things are going on this
direction, at least they are pushed on this
direction. But I also can't predict that every
day on that side, on the AI side,
are some new,
some something new. It's also hard to follow
there.
But other than that, I think for Kubernetes
definitely will stay
for a few years.
Again, there are people who recently moved there
and especially for enterprise companies, which means that
you'll get five years support for
whatever products, three years support is already there.
So I think Kubernetes will be, will stay
here for a long time. There was a
talk in one of the conferences
a couple of years ago. The idea was
simply that we make some new things. They
are like great, they do the job, they're
elegant, nice, small things and then we make
them complex.
And at some complexity people say that, hey,
it's
too much. We need something like something that
does the job, something small, something easier to
manage, then we create it. And then again,
it becomes complex because of everyone wants to
do something extra. So I think Kubernetes is
in that stage now. Initially it was
still doing a great job, but it was
like just to run the containers in a
more production like environment with peeling and running
multiple nodes, etcetera.
But nowadays you can even manage your infrastructure
through Kubernetes with tools like Crossplane and others.
Yeah. It again became complex. So probably at
some point someone will say, yeah, that's too
much. I just want to run my workloads
and here's a new tool.
It's faster, it's blah, blah, blah. But I
don't know when this will happen or how
this will happen. I really can't predict that
much. But I think it will come to
that point because again, Kubernetes is a great
project. It has now
you can do a lot of stuff with
it. But yeah, it's also too complex and
hard to learn. People will start over at
some point probably
to run their workloads. I don't want to
say easier,
like in a more, yeah,
easier, but in a less complex environment. All
right. I'll allow that. Thanks. All right. I
have two more questions for you. One of
them a few minutes ago, mentioned having one
cluster or multiple clusters, and I think this
is
a problem that a lot of people struggle
with is should I have one huge cluster
with all my work loads or should I
be running many small clusters? What are your
thoughts on that? What would you consider best
practice? As a consultant, my answer will be,
it depends if you have like doing multi
tenancy, if you have different type of workloads
or running
many namespaces or different environments like dev test
in one cluster, maybe it makes sense to
separate them just because it would be easier
to manage that cluster. Manage meaning like to
do the upgrades, etcetera. So I mean, putting
everything into one cluster is like putting all
your eggs into one basket,
I think if you can separate things, makes
more sense to have more
availability or like managing things easier. But that
doesn't also mean that instead of one huge
cluster, have a hundred clusters. That's also probably
not the best approach.
But clusters with one pod each. Yeah, yeah.
For example, yeah. That's also not the Then
just run back around, right? In a VM.
You don't need Kubernetes there. Yeah, if you
can separate things to different clusters, I think
it makes
sense to me because then if you lose
one cluster, then the others might be running.
Or if you are doing an upgrade to
one of them, things fail, then you can
get the knowledge and then do things. You
have different environments, right? So you have dev
tests, staging, production, whatever. If they are on
separate clusters, then something fails on dev and
you'll see that, yeah, okay, I need to
I should do things differently on test and
staging, etcetera. But if you put all of
them at this not the production, but the
others into one cluster in different namespaces,
then if during the upgrade if things fail
then you'll lose all your environments. So in
that sense separating them
makes sense
to me,
But again, if you have the resource to
be able to manage those, etcetera. So it's,
I don't know if there's a right decision
there or the right answer to this. Yeah.
I think you've gave it. So I'm gonna
try and present it back to you at
one sentence. What I heard you say there
was that Kubernetes at the container workload level
gives us redundancy through horizontal scale. And then
depending on your company or teams, risk appetite,
at some point, you're gonna need cluster redundancy
as we're maybe splitting your workloads across Split
your workloads horizontally as well. Your clusters horizontally
as well may be the appropriate solution. So,
yeah, I think definitely a good message in
there for people listening.
Oh, alright. Thanks thanks for rephrasing. That was
even the right message. Thanks.
My superpower is to listen to people and
Thanks. See what they say back to them
and, you know, hopefully make that
Yeah. It is. Yeah. It Alright. Let's finish
with one last question. Please feel free to
take a minute to think about this one,
but people who are listening to this, they're
going to come away from us with two
things. One, Kubernetes is scary and everyone to
do this or, oh, there's a lot to
learn there. How do I get started? I'm
going to do this tomorrow or tonight. Yeah.
Do you have three actionable tips for anyone
listening on how to improve their Kubernetes skills
or even get started. Three tips. And please
feel free to take a minute if you
need it. On on the tree? Okay. Sorry,
I've got a book here. Go. No.
Problem about learning a new technology, whatever that
is,
is to have some sort of motivation or
a case to do it. So I also
struggle.
I used to struggle with learning things. So
for example, I want to learn, let's say
Python,
but what will I be doing it? So
before that,
wanted to learn Perl some years ago, beginning
of 2000s,
but then I was like, yeah, I was
reading books, but then I needed to do
something with it to actually learn. I did
some stuff with Python. So we had many
shell scripts to
connect to Oracle clusters,
which was a command line tool.
Scripts were getting the data, like select some
things, writing to a file.
Then we were gripping from file, all scripts
everywhere. And then we were just doing something
with those scripts. I was like,
should be doing something different. And then with
Python, with the Oracle client, I was actually
just like a normal programming language, getting the
data, doing things there
in some structures and then pointing. It was
running faster. It was great, etcetera. Having a
motivation, a use case to learn technology is
the, I think, key point. So you set
up a Kubernetes cluster. It's fairly easy on
your local machine. You can just do it
with minikube or kind, but then what? So
yeah, running it there, it's running what there?
That's also a thing. But in general, for
Kubernetes,
my first recommendation is to follow Kubernetes the
hard way from Kelsey Hightower.
I think that will
make people understand what's happening under the hood.
If you like command line tools, if you
like Linux and stuff, I think it's
a lot of fun. But maybe it might
not be so much fun if you are,
let's say from Windows background or doing different
things than those there. But for a new
starter for Kubernetes,
I think this is the really first recommendation,
I would say. Kubernetes the hard way. There
are a lot of online
resources.
I think the problem is which one is
the
good quality. Your channel, for example. That's what
I was going to say. So there are
a lot of people doing things, but what
you do is perfect. Thank you. Appreciate that.
Yeah. I'll send you the check after the
interview.
Thanks. My Ivan number and the lulls and
lowers. No. Yeah. There are a few people
actually creating great content in general. I I
think if you just do a little bit
Google search, you'll people would will find those.
Just listen and see what people are doing.
That would be my second thing.
And the third, I learn things by hands
on stuff. Most
cloud providers
give you some credits
to try things out. Creditors, just get it.
Even if it is a managed service,
have it use it. Try to
create an NGINX server there with the certificate,
with the domain DNS entry, everything.
So try to set up a system that
actually works because
yeah, in the end it won't be only
about Kubernetes. You will need to get some
SSR certificates maybe with sort manager, let's encrypt
or you
will need ingress, you will need some static
IPs, you will need DNS entry somewhere. People
probably can use, make use of those free
credits and
think hands on experience is hard.
I know, again, goes to the motivation,
but you also need to try out stuff,
I think. Nice.
All right. That was fantastic. I heard there
was one piece of strategical advice, right? The
strategy is
scratch your own itch. I
think a lot of people do try to
learn technologies.
They don't have anything at hand to apply
that. And it's like learning a language. Right?
If you don't go and speak to people
in that language, it's not gonna get the
skill. It's not gonna work. Yeah. You need
to move on. So make sure you scratch
your own edge and do something. Then you
gave us three pieces of tactical advice, which
I also loved. One of them, go to
kills high towers. Kubernetes is a hard way.
If you wanna learn Kubernetes from the bottom
up, fantastic resource. It's still maintained. It's still
updated. Go check it out. Second piece of
advice was to follow the Rawkode Academy. Appreciate
that one. Thank you very much. But I
also
learn with other people. And this is a
community effort. I'll shout out Annie East Ehrlich,
Sycam,
Canal,
Victor Farsek, so many great channels that they're
teaching DevOps,
infrastructures, code, Kubernetes. Go learn with them. It's
a great way to to follow along and
keep up to date. This is a volatile
landscape. It changes all the time. It can
be hard to keep up Yeah. That other
people do the hard work for you. That's
that's a great great piece of advice.
And then your last piece of advice there
was cloud provider credits, which I love. Right?
You're right. AWS, GCP, they all offer you
$300
to sign up. So just spin up a
cluster and scratch your own edge, deploy
an NGINX server, deploy a database, deploy a
WordPress, not WordPress because they're self employed right
now. No. Apply something else.
Yeah. Deploy stuff and use it. And even
with that one workload, which I would never
encourage anyone to put one workload on Kubernetes.
But stick one thing you care about on
that cluster, and I guarantee you'll then start
to explore, okay, how do I make sure
this is up? What do health checks look
like? What does monitoring look like? It'll gauge
you the path will write itself, hopefully, and
have some fun. Let's not forget that. Just
enjoy it while you do it. Awesome. Exactly.
That was fantastic. I really appreciate you taking
the time to sit down with me today
and just share your knowledge with all of
the listeners. So thank you very much. Do
you have any parting words before we say
goodbye? I also thank you the invitation. I
really had fun with the talk. Was great.
Yeah, Kubernetes is there. Again,
a lot of resources out there to learn.
And again, it's community work, as you said.
One more thing that they could join the
CNCF and Kubernetes Slack channels
where they could also interact with the projects
like the in their channels, as well as
Kubernetes,
ask questions, meet with people.
That's all that would also be another maybe
a bonus recommendation.
Bonus stuff. Love it. Yeah.
Just reach out to people. This community is
quite
helpful,
and everyone is welcome to ask questions,
get help. So
be part of the community, and I'm sure
people will be you and you'll get to
some point quite fast. Awesome. Well, thank you
again for joining me, and thank you to
everyone listening. Have a great day. Thank you
very much. Bye bye. Thanks for joining us.
If you wanna keep up with us, consider
subscribing to the podcast on your favorite podcasting
app or even go to CloudNativeCompass.fm.
And if you want us to talk with
someone specific or cover a specific topic,
reach out to us on any social media
platform. Until next time when exploring the cloud
native landscape
on 3.
On 3. 1,
2,
3.
Don't forget your compass. Forget your compass.